so today's topic YouTube's unfair
treatment of you smaller youtubers in
favor of bigger youtubers so essentially
YouTube is being sued right now by a
couple of LGBT creators our LGBTQ plus
content is being demonetised restricted
and not sent out to viewers which is
highly affected our ability to reach the
community that we strongly want to help
this is a crazy right-wing activist and
political commentators always like
YouTube is censoring us and then LGBTQ
bazoo or else like YouTube is censoring
us so it just sounds like you do with
sensory everybody yeah that's what it
really sounds like at this point maybe
cuz everybody said you'd be censoring
them maybe YouTube is distance or in the
extremes I'm in the middle and I'm also
being maybe just YouTube is being Oprah
we do not automatically
demonetized LGBTQ rumors like I have one
lesbian in your taxi of thumb now you're
tied to all instant flack so we work
incredibly hard to make sure that our
systems are fair we have an m/l fairness
initiative and malice answering machine
learning ml stands from what the [ __ ] is
lying okay let me just say that okay
hey I am fine with YouTube showing
favoritism do you big youtubers because
that's just the way it's always function
to say otherwise it's absolute hogwash
and nonsense I mean the mere fact that
bigger youtubers have access to some
kind of customer service line where they
directly can talk to somebody to have
their problems solved it's already
indicative of you showing favoritism and
special features to people who bring
more money to your platform
so let's not pretend like there's a huge
fairness platform involved with YouTube
and I'm used to it even as a smaller
creator yes because we've had incidents
where I have reacted to a video for
example yeah right and my video gets Dee
monetizing it's age-restricted meanwhile
a bigger youtuber is reacting to the
same video okay with even worse language
and somehow theirs is not only monetized
but it has no age restrictions and the
problem with YouTube is
that they have strict rules is that
these rules are unclear and so what ends
up happening is that you don't
understand where you're doing things
that are wrong bro we're a big youtuber
can call and figure some [ __ ] out for me
it's very confusing because I I get
demonetised on the most random of videos
and I don't even know what was
demonetised about it so I can't curb
that behavior cuz I don't know what's
wrong with the behavior at all how do
you want people to improve whenever you
give a roof and the one of the rule is
at our discretion you know it's gonna be
pocus because it doesn't mean anything
they don't our discretion means we don't
have to give you any reason if our
discretion we're being discreet about
our reasons that's what it means
hey if we don't want you here we're not
watching here and we're not gonna tell
you why it's our discretion we're
discreet about it get the [ __ ] out of
our professors and my problem is that as
a small youtuber who's like you know
seeing the changes that are happening on
YouTube that's why I'm not so reliant on
income from this platform because I
understand it's very fickle it's
constantly changing the rules are
shifting they're trying to figure out
how to navigate and so it may not have
room for me down the line and how I like
to make videos and I'm not the type of
person who likes to adapt I like to
adapt provided it's within the
parameters of Who I am meaning I'm not
gonna start doing some corny as vlog
videos just so I can be on YouTube
that's not what I want to make I like
the kind of content we make right now
but it's possible that three years from
now this content may be outright bent I
don't know and their own moderation team
people who used to work for you to say
yeah we showed favoritism to larger
youtubers so for her to be on this on
this Fairness Act [ __ ] like boo boo
stop lying it's a soft band what it's a
soft man if you're not showing the
content and you're not ready to just
show the contents of people it's a soft
band yeah it's just like you know what
shadow shadow batting something so
whatever yeah it's not a band I mean
you're they're good for you to do your
thing but we're not gonna show it to
people we're not gonna use everything
we've [ __ ] everything up we're not
going to allow you to prosper I don't I
don't like the term soft man because it
makes it sound like it's very delicate
no it's actually very deadly yeah it's
more like a poisonous band yeah it's
just that hypocrite yeah yeah you feel
there you still doing your thing it's
able to produce that's so good
but we're not gonna let you broadcast
yeah
do you see what they did with the
trending top this is the trending tab
visualized there are over 40,000 videos
here with over 2,000 unique channels all
represented on this graph here so the
y-axis is the average view count they
got before they got on training so as
soon as we got we see them on trending
how many views do they have would that
happen so we can think of that as sort
of the barrier to them getting on
training how many views they needed to
get on trending and then we have the
number of unique trending videos so
let's do a for instance let's say you
have I don't know Lele pons she seems to
have trended about ten times on the
training tab and she it took her about
four million views on average to get on
trending those ten time who do we find
with a lot of times on trending the
answer is overwhelmingly traditional
media traditional media as in ESPN as in
The Ellen Show Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Kimmel
Stephen Colbert Netflix MBA a CNN box
this is not due to the fact they're
getting more views than these other
youtubers are for example if Logan
Paul's barrier to trending is about 11
million views then no matter how much he
uploads he's a lot less likely to trend
frequently than someone like ESPN whose
barrier to trending is on average about
500,000 views I've been on the trending
tab before I was number one at one point
on a specific video on two of the
matches well not today [ __ ] and here's
a thing they changed it because if you
than you're like what and I just wish
they would just be honest about the fact
that hey this is an unfair platform my
problem is not that they're unfair I've
kind of just embraced it and learned to
work with it my problem is that they're
not honest about it and they're not
transparent about it which then makes it
hard for little creators to adapt and I
think YouTube is gonna have to come to
terms with some facts which is one does
it want to have the best content or does
it want to has the most presentable
content and I think trying to have both
is impossible because as somebody who
makes content that isn't necessarily the
most presentable to the whole public I I
still make content that is very poignant
that does touch people in a real way and
when YouTube decides hey you're not
presentable therefore I'm going to
restrict you and make sure
most people cannot watch your stuff it
is very frustrating because it makes D
incentivizes me to continue creating
content and I'll see you guys a perfect
example I had to Evan up came video that
was upright that sketch now okay it's
like millions of views on Facebook and
originally when I posted it okay
this was posted way months back it was
somehow deemed unacceptable for most
people to watch it was stuck at 20k
views Oh stuffer for six seven months it
was there you took it down I put up a
longer version okay it was D monetized
right I'll put up a longer version all
of a sudden it's at 100k views in only a
week okay it's monetized what that tells
me is that when they D monetize it
sometimes they may just flag it as being
hey restrict this from most people and
what really gets to me when I'm watching
stuff is that someone is manually
confirming or denying and so whatever
political bias that this person has this
moderator they're just [ __ ] yeah nope
and then I reapplied and the next model
is like I like this push it forward so
I'm really just at the whim of somebody
who I don't understand I had videos that
were seen as risky I had them confirmed
afterwards and then they did get
monetized and then once they got to like
five hundred thousand views they got
ridi monetized so it's it's so fickle
it's unfair I go to the manual process
us confirm it and then later you
manually unconfirmed it randomly and I
cannot change that I don't know it just
it's hard for me to understand how
anything works you reload every video
that was unconfirmed all of them just
feel over school trouble Matrix Reloaded
it's too much trouble man honestly like
one when something gets demonetized I
just leave it alone now and I leave it
there and you know let the viewers watch
it we made the content for you guys but
it makes me focus my time elsewhere
because I need to make my revenue
elsewhere because focusing on this [ __ ]
I'm like I don't I don't trust it cuz it
got harder and harder first they were
trying to say like oh you know we're
trying to ban language then they ban the
copyright for the song which I
understand I get it but but the only
people that are really making money is
people that are doing make up people
their own video games and there's not
really an avenue
no I don't wanna unboxed and play with
toys that's not my thing
you know I don't have time for that I'm
not gonna want to do that I have my own
thing but I cannot do it even its most
frustrating is that they're telling you
you're not breaking any rules but we
can't allow you to play that video it's
exactly like if I was saying and the
police was arresting them like listen
you didn't break any rules on the road
but we're gonna seize your permit you're
not able to roll that doesn't make any
sense especially the fact that you
didn't break any rules and then you turn
around to the office and you're like why
but why well it's my own discretion I
mean that's what it is
um I guess you know I hope they win
their lawsuit I hope there is some kind
of real change in YouTube culture
because they need to be more transparent
with this stuff the longer they keep is
like hypocrisy yeah the secrecy then the
harder is gonna become for creators to
really toll the line and understand what
they can or can't do so that's pretty
much all I got
leave your comments below we want to
know what you guys think are you guys
encountering this process and also if
you guys aren't countering this problem
let us know how you are dealing with it
we want to hear your opinions so be sure
to LIKE comment subscribe you know we
get demonetized a lot so all your likes
and comments help us to reach more
people so please be sure to do that to
every video when you do watch them cuz I
don't like to ask for it I don't think
we ever do that being said I'm going to
start only because it seems like the
only way we're gonna get seen to the
algorithm is if you guys like in comment
so you know people have been commenting
and being saying like oh yeah why why
you guys are not so popular why are you
not that much popular like your your
content is banging your countenance
booming it's dope it's dope is dope why
don't you guys have more subscribers
this is one of the reasons yeah so share
it like it whatever you got let us have
your support please
[Music]